c'est dans la bagagerie au premier étage
de l'internât que le feu s'est déclaré
les quelques élèves présents dans le
bâtiment ont été rapidement évacués il
aura fallu l'intervention d'une
quarantaine de pompiers pour venir à
bout des flammes
la maîtrise du feu était un petit peu un
petit peu délicate compte tenu de la
configuration du bâtiment et de
l'important dégagement de fumée qui a
nécessité à nos personnels d'intervenir
sous protection respiratoire
les dispositifs coupe eu d'alarmé
c'était ont parfaitement joué leur rôle
donc même si effectivement le de
sinistre était important le feu
normalement ne devait pas spécialement
se propager dans le reste du bâtiment
aymeric et baptiste sont élèves en
terminale ils étaient à l'extérieur du
bâtiment lorsqu'ils ont vu une colonne
de fumée s'élevait à proximité de leurs
chambres les femmes dans la bagagerie
qui va nous par exemple en interne on
est un peu mois par chance il y avait
rien d'important dans ma valise juste
perdu des habits des trucs comme ça mais
c'est très bizarre c'est très
particulier on fait comme on peut on
essaye de rassurer ce qui va ce type
leur et ceux qui sont pas bien protocole
sanitaire oblige le nombre d' interne
dans le bâtiment est actuellement réduit
et une centaine d'élèves leur accueil
est temporairement compromis on est en
train de faire l' expertise avec les
services de pompiers pour voir
effectivement quelles sont les
conséquences c'est surtout l'épreuve de
toxicité ou de circulation des fumées il
n'y a pas de dégâts sur les chambres n'y
a pas de dégâts structurels a priori
pour l'instant nous avons pris la
précaution de d'évacuer les élèves
internes pour cette soirée est
certainement mon avis quand même pour la
semaine pas de vacances anticipées en
revanche pour les élèves les cours
reprendront de manière normale dès
demain